so it looks like uh it's happening guys
um i got some breaking news that's why
this video is gonna be a little bit less
edited and structured than usual but
this is uh something that just came out
a while ago and i do think we have to
talk about it one piece apparently is
preparing for the final saga slash final
arc
what the hell
seriously um so in case you don't know
what's happening we got a post from the
official one piece twitter account in
japanese where we basically got a
handwritten message by ichiro oda the
author of one piece and in this message
he talks about a bunch of things but the
core thing is one piece is gonna be on
break for about four weeks so about a
month which is gonna be like four
chapters in a row basically which is
relatively rare oda sensei as you might
know takes his breaks but never in that
sort of scale it's something quite new
that we're not used to and so he gives
us a bunch of explanations for why this
is happening this is going to be in july
quite soon so we're going to get like
one or two more chapters and then the
breaks gonna happen there's a bunch of
things he throws into that post let's
let's i would say let's start actually
with the most important part oda wants
to take a break in part apparently
because he wants to take the time to
prepare the story and prepare his
thoughts for the final of the story and
preparing to finish and wrap up one
piece which let's be real is
huge i mean we're talking about the
series ending that has been going on for
over 20 years it's something that has
been hinted at and oda has mentioned
over and over and over again that he
will want to end this at some point in
the next five years and it always kept
pushing forward and right now honestly
with wano and everything that's going on
it doesn't really feel like we're super
close to the ending but once again this
seems to be proof that we're actually
closer to the end than we all might
think which
man called sandman on twitter who
translates a lot of the shonen jump and
one piece related news from japanese is
it once again people on twitter keep
saying it's the final arc and after wano
the final arc is gonna happen but to be
fair this post isn't quite as obvious
but it does indeed say that oda kind of
phrases is as he wants to revise the
story
so he can start wrapping up the final
arc or final saga it's kind of a bit
ambiguous here which he means though
let's be real it can't be a final arc
because even if we skipped elbaf which
is unlikely it would be left tail and
the final war which is already two arcs
so i personally would say it's
definitely talking about the final saga
which would include a bunch of arcs that
together kind of form the endgame of one
piece and so basically his argument is
that he wants to revise the story in
other words collect his thoughts and
structure everything out in a proper way
so he can start wrapping up the story
now it sounds like and people on twitter
obviously make it sound like one piece
is about to end very soon it's wano
we're wrapping up one or right away um
before this break still and then we're
gonna head right into the last arc find
the one piece one piece over clearly
this is not what this is about it's
definitely going into a direction where
one piece or oda and the team in general
want to move things along to push one
piece towards the ending but it says
nothing about you know rushing there or
that it's gonna be right away so it says
neither that wano is gonna end right
away before this break which is very
unrealistic i think or even if it might
happen it will take a while until we
actually leave wano and wrap everything
up there and then secondly it also
doesn't mean that right after this break
we go into like the final arc in the
final saga right away so i think what it
really says is it's a summer break oda
wants to collect his thoughts write his
notes structure the story and prepare
everything in calm without having to
worry about writing a manga in the
meantime and then basically prepare for
the upcoming arcs that like as a package
together form the final big saga of the
story which i would personally assume is
elbaf love tale maybe roadstar who knows
and then the final war however that will
take place in whatever shape or form
another reason for the break which i
think is important to mention because
the only reason isn't only that oda
wants to sit down take a break now and
then you know write and like plan
everything out for the final season but
it's also because he is involved in the
netflix series where he originally
wanted to travel to africa to visit the
filming which was got cancelled because
of covet but it still played into that
that he originally wanted to take that
time off um that didn't happen and the
second thing is that he's also directing
film red which is scheduled in july i
want to say to come out here in japan
which is two major project where he's
directly involved and where he basically
wanted to take time off to take care of
those projects as well because the man
already sleeps little enough i don't
think we have to have him sleep even
less while like writing the story so the
film movie red coming out soon and
netflix series he's involved in both of
them so directly that he just needed to
take a big break to still work basically
and make sure those projects um are
coming to a conclusion or shaping the
way that he envisions them to be so it's
these three reasons gathering his
thoughts a movie and the netflix tv show
which is why he takes a break i still
think it's giant news but i think also
at the same time we should all not
overreact it's a lot more vague in the
japanese version i think personally than
people make it seem on twitter so it
does theme in conclusion it does seem
like we're moving towards the final arc
in one piece it's about to happen i do
think sounds apparently like wano is
about to wrap up relatively soon not
necessarily in the next few chapters but
soon and then we're gonna move into the
final saga which is gonna consist of
multiple arcs most likely so we're still
years away from one piece ending in case
you're worried about that or in case you
wanted it to rub out very soon i don't
think that's gonna happen but
nonetheless i think um we're probably
talking less than ten years so maybe the
five-year timeline that oda has
originally scheduled out last year or
was it two years ago already i think
that is getting more and more likely so
we're definitely in the end game now but
nonetheless since we're talking about
scheduling everything out i do think
it's all gonna take its time there's so
many things to wrap up so many places we
still have to visit so many enemies
still to face i think we're good for a
while with content and honestly i'm
really excited to move onwards to the
end game meet shanks meet blackbeard
find the one piece and hopefully take
down the world government so yeah thanks
for tuning in for this quick update if
you want something to watch next i
strongly recommend you check out my
review of yamato joining the crew here